I'm going to share with you a simple
three-step framework that trains you to
stop saying um and ah every single time
you speak. Those are what I call the
non-words. They're the sounds that you
make to fill the silence. And then there
are the filler words. They're the words
you use to fill the silence. Like, so,
and do you know what I mean? I've been
coaching communication skills to Fortune
500 companies and millions of people.
And the biggest problem I see is highly
qualified professionals littering their
speech with non-words and filler words.
It's auditory clutter that adds no value
to their communication. As a result,
when they speak, they come across
unclear and hard to follow. And even
worse, people judge them as less
credible than they actually are. And I
don't want you to fall into this trap,
either. So, please, if there's one thing
you're going to commit to today, learn
this process I'm about to go through,
because it's the difference between
being ignored and being taken seriously.
The first step in you doing this is you
need to engage in awareness, first of
all.
And what I mean by awareness as being
the first step is, well, what are your
filler words? What are your non-words?
Really start to be conscious of this.
And the way you can do this is you just
need to record a video of yourself. And
this video is going to be a little bit
longer, because I want you to record a
10-minute video of yourself answering
the question, what are the three reasons
why you want to improve your
communication skills? Make sure when
you're recording this video, it's an
impromptu take, meaning you haven't
scripted or rehearsed anything. And make
sure you don't stop the recording until
the 10 minutes is over. You want to
tease out the non-words and filler
words. I know you'll feel the urge to
stop the recording when you stuff up,
but this is an important part of
awareness. Now, when you're reviewing
that video, get it transcribed. And once
you've got it transcribed, look through
the transcript. Use a red highlighter
and highlight all of your non-words and
all of your filler words. What are the
sounds I make when I when I'm unsure?
What are the words I use when I'm
uncomfortable with a pause? You need to
become fully aware of what your
non-words and filler words are. First
step is awareness. Second step is
deliberate practice.
It means that you need to dedicate time.
And I would encourage you to do this
with a partner. Do this with someone who
can help you in the process. I want you
to find someone, this is step two,
who you can deliberately practice with.
And you say to your partner, "Hold a
bell. If you don't have a bell,
have a horn. But if you don't have a
horn, these are just the ways that I
learned.
What my mentor would do with me is he
sat there with an air horn and he goes,
"Vin, I want you to speak for the next
10 minutes. And every non-word or every
filler word that you're going to use,
I'm going to press the air horn." And it
was very uncomfortable because it was so
loud. And he would literally sit there
and he goes, "Vin, I'd like you to
speak. I'd like you to answer this
question for me that you would most
likely encounter at work. And then Vin,
you've got to speak for 10 minutes,
okay? You ready? Go." And literally as
I'm speaking, because I've done the
awareness step and I'm aware of what my
non-words and filler words are, I gave
him that list. And every single time I
hit one of those non-words and fillers,
And it was so excruciating that I'd
slightly flinch.
But that deliberate practice and you
don't have to use an air horn, that's
just rather dramatic, but I love that. I
love the dramatic nature of that. It
just really anchors the lesson. But you
could also get a friend to clap.
So every time you say an um,
they clap. And they're waiting every
time you you you you you pause and you
say something strange or you you make a
sound.
And it's slightly a little bit of
negative reinforcement. But it helps you
get rid of the unwanted behavior because
it makes you now that you're aware, now
now you're super conscious of it, which
is really important, right?
And there's a little step here too that
you can take. And this is a part of
deliberate practice. It's another form
of deliberate practice.
And the other form of deliberate
practice is to overdo it.
Once you become aware of your non-words
and your filler words, overdo it. Do a
deliberate practice session where you
litter
what you're about to say as you're
practicing with ums and ahs. So an
example of that is you you go, "All
right. So I say the word like a lot. I
say the word okay a lot. Do you know
what I mean a lot?" And then I also say
um and ah a lot. Okay, so now here I'll
do it I'll practice.
>> [clears throat]
>> Um, you know like
uh, I um, want to
uh, like um, you know
improve my communication skills you know
basically because um, uh,
so like
uh,
and you overdo it.
This is a really funny way to practice
because it really brings to the
forefront of your mind the words that
are causing the issue. So instead of
just being aware you're actually acting
out the awareness. So it's a wonderful
way to practice as well. And then after
you've done that you've got it out of
your system then go into the deliberate
practice the version of the deliberate
practice where you are getting a
negative reinforcement every time you're
doing it. So that's a wonderful way to
be doing it. Okay so this is a wonderful
way to actually practice. If you're
finding this helpful and you want to
learn communication skills more formally
with me I want to do something for you
that I've never done before. For a
limited [music] time you can enroll in
my flagship online program the Stage
Academy for $499 USD. I've distilled the
80/20 of everything you need to know
when it comes to being a better
communicator and public speaker. That's
where you go to learn and you also get 6
months access to my stage community.
That's where you go to apply alongside
hundreds of people working on the exact
same skill. We do monthly communication
challenges that pushes you to practice
your new skills and you'll get access to
a live monthly Q&A with me and you will
also get access to our full library of
past recordings which includes exclusive
sessions with other communication
experts including me. This month we've
got a comedian Andrew Tarvin coming into
our community doing a live Q&A on how to
become more humorous. And yes we all can
actually learn to be more funny. We only
taking a small group each month to keep
the community focused active and full of
people who are serious about practicing
this skill together. So if you're ready
to level up your communication click on
the link in the description to join us.
And then the third thing you do,
number three,
is now you bring it into your life.
You bring the practice into your life.
So, now in your everyday conversations,
you just don't have the friend who's
standing there clapping at you.
But you're doing everything you can in
every single conversation to absolutely
minimize the amount of non-words and
fillers that you use.
It's why I hope you notice that every
time I speak and every time I'm
teaching,
there's very little non-words and
fillers.
Very few.
And when you listen to me in that way,
the information that I'm delivering,
there are no obstacles
for the message.
The message is crisp, it's clear, and
it's clean.
That way it's easier for you to
comprehend.
Otherwise, if I've got so many ums and
ahs and filler words and non-words and I
start to litter my communication with
it, you just experienced before.
It It would be so hard for me to deliver
anything.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, um if I just um was, you know,
talking about like awareness and then
like um
uh then I was talking about uh uh
deliberate uh practice and you know, um
I uh
I I go to Do you see what that does? It
creates
so much difficulty for you. You have to
work so hard now to follow what I'm
saying. Whereas, if you could just
remove the ums and the ahs through the
simple three-step process, what that
does is it makes you so easy to listen
to. And that's a huge part of
engagement. And why do I keep speaking
to engagement? Why am I speaking about
the importance of engagement when it
comes to influence? Well, it's because
if you want to be more influential, my
goodness, first be really easy to
understand.
Otherwise, people have to use so much of
their cognitive capacity to even just
listen to you.
Whereas, when you make listening to you
easier,
influence [music] becomes
so much simpler.
It becomes a lighter lift.
Because people want to keep listening to
you talk. There's a desire to keep
listening because
of the ease at which it is their
experience because of the ease that
comes with listening to you.
There's a pleasure to it because so many
people are not good at this. So you've
got that three-step process there.
I hope that does help you on your
journey of practicing minimizing
non-words and filler words.